In this segment, we go
through a quick review
of a few properties of
the Bernoulli process
that we already know.
We start by thinking about the
number of successes or arrivals
in the first n time slots.
This is the following quantity.
At each time we add a
0 or a 1, depending on
whether we've had
a success or not,
then by adding those numbers,
we get the total number
of successes.
Now we already know that the
number of successes in n trials
obeys a binomial distribution,
so the probability
of having k successes is given
by the binomial probabilities.
And this is a formula that
holds for k equal to 0 up to n,
which are the possible numbers
for the random variable S.
For this random variable,
we know the expected value.
It's n times p.
And we also know its
variance, which is n times
p times 1 minus p.
Another random
variable of interest
is the time until the
first success or arrival.
So this is defined
to be the smallest
i for which the random
variable Xi is equal to 1.
We have done this
calculation in the past.
The probability that the first
success appears at time k is
the same as the probability
that the first k minus 1 trials
resulted in 0's.
And then, the k-th
trial resulted in a 1.
And so the probability
of this is 1 minus p,
the probability of 0, and
we have k minus 1 of them,
times p, the probability
that the next trial gives us
a success.
And this formula is valid
for k being 1, 2, and so on,
which is the range
of possible values
of this random variable T1.
This is the familiar
geometric distribution
that we have dealt with
on several occasions.
And in particular, we know the
expected value and the variance
of the geometric
random variable.